[Music]
this is a chase scene from
1924. it's from the movie sherlock jr
and in it buster keaton seems to almost
get hit by a train
with extremely limited special effects
the filmmakers had to come up with an
innovative way to create the illusion so
they shot the sequence
backwards then reversed the film
since then hollywood has developed
countless ways to make car chases
feel more real and visceral to audiences
from modifying cars
to placing cameras right in the seat of
the action
and without each of these innovations we
wouldn't have gotten to the ultimate
spectacle that
is the fast and furious franchise let's
take a look
at how the car chase has evolved over
100 years in hollywood
this is the scene that set the standard
for all modern car chases
it's from the 1968 steve mcqueen movie
bullet
and it's iconic partly because of the
characters look chalmers let's
understand each other i don't like you
but also because of their cars this mean
looking dodge charger is a muscle car
a type of car that exploded in
popularity during the late 60s in the us
this new sleeker generation was
basically built for informal drag racing
with big v8 engines and rear-wheel drive
the hero car and bullet was a ford
mustang
the first major pony car a more compact
sporty take on the muscle car
and it's this combination of streamlined
design and v8 engines that made these
cars powerful
and maneuverable enough to pull off
daring stunts
like racing through the hills of san
francisco at 110 miles per hour
bullet also had another advantage
smaller and more rugged cameras
which allowed shooting to happen in
actual streets before this movie
most directors shot chase scenes on
studio sets since they were dealing with
cameras that looked like this
to fill in the backdrop filmmakers would
use rear projection where you project a
moving image onto a screen behind the
actor
like in this chase scene from the first
bond movie dr no
where sean connery's steering doesn't
seem to match the movement of his
convertible
bullet was one of the first big
hollywood movies to rely on the lighter
reflex 35
2 camera so the crew could shoot
entirely on location
and also take audiences inside the cards
they mounted cameras on the hoods sides
and interiors of each vehicle
so viewers could feel every bump and
lurch
this dynamic camera style was most
famously used in the chase from the
movie the french connection
the filmmakers mounted cameras on the
hood front bumper and dashboard of gene
hackman's pontiac
these multiple angles along with
handheld camera work from the back seat
of the car
showed all the action from the driver's
perspective the result makes that bond
chase look like a casual spin
but higher stakes car chases can also be
more dangerous
the french connection chase was filmed
on uncleared streets in new york without
permits
among other drivers and passers-by these
barely avoided collisions
they happened for real and this crash
was entirely unplanned
at the wheel of the white ford was a
civilian driver who was
uninvolved in the shoot all this
happened even with actors sometimes
driving slower than what you see on film
a standard trick used to reduce risk see
how some cars exhaust pipes are blowing
smoke faster than normal
that's because filmmakers on french
connection used a technique known as
undercranking where they filmed some of
the scene at a lowered frame rate
capturing fewer frames makes movement
look faster basically the opposite of
slow motion
you can also see this in vanishing point
released the same year
barry newman's character bets he can
drive his dodge challenger from denver
to san francisco in 15
hours that require a constant pace of
some 80 miles an hour
but in many sequences like this hot race
with a jaguar
the actors were only driving at 50. so
the filmmakers created the illusion of
speed
by undercranking the camera to half its
normal frame rate
making the cars look like they're flying
undercranking is still used today most
notably in the 2015 movie
mad max fury road but heavy
undercranking works best for settings
that don't have a lot of people moving
around
mad max and vanishing point were perfect
fits with
scenes that take place in the desert in
scenes that have lots of pedestrians the
effects can make human movement look
jerky and fake like what you see in old
silent comedies
so city chase scenes can only use the
technique sparingly
the paris chase and the 1998 thriller
ronin where robert de niro's pujo
pursues a bmw
didn't use undercranking at all to
actually drive at these daredevil speeds
you
pretty much always need a stunt driver
so the filmmakers have to find ways to
make it look like the actor
not the stunt driver is controlling the
car in ronin
they had right hand drive cars fitted
with fake left side steering wheels
the actor in this case robert de niro
would pretend to drive for the close-ups
while the stunt driver to their right
did all the actual maneuvering on a
steering wheel positioned out of shot
but having the stun performer in the
other seat limits the angles you can
shoot
and what if the stunt driver can't be in
the vehicle at all
the solution came from a movie with
exactly zero car chases
seabiscuit the stunt team on that movie
built a special rig for filming
horse race scenes eventually that rig
evolved into a smaller more versatile
version designed specifically for
filming
car chases known as the biscuit it's
basically a vehicle that you can put
other vehicles on one that can be
reassembled into different
configurations
like a giant lego truck the rig makes it
look like an actor is doing the driving
while a stunt person actually steers
from the driver's pod
this pod can be mounted anywhere on the
platform so filmmakers can basically get
any angle they want the biscuit rig made
it possible to film some of hollywood's
most famous car scenes over the past two
decades
from this scene in the hangover to the
many chases in baby driver
take this scene in the movie drive where
a guy chasing ryan gosling's character
hits the back of his mustang to make it
spin out
after shooting the whole thing with two
stunt drivers to get all the exterior
shots they filmed it again with ryan in
the car and the car
on the biscuit rig to get the close-up
and interior angles
a stunt driver drove the biscuit while
talking to ryan through a radio to help
him mimic all the movements on his
steering wheel
in the resulting scene it looks like
ryan is in control of the vehicle
and because he's immersed in the action
we as the audience are too
finding ways to make chase scenes feel
more and more immersive calls for
increasingly creative rig
systems like in the movie extraction
with a 12-minute fight and chase
sequence designed to look like
one continuous take to pull this off
director sam hargrave strapped himself
with his camera to the foot of a chase
vehicle
from there he could follow the action
from behind unclip himself and then move
the action
into the car for a seamless outside to
inside shot
this progression of bigger and bigger
chase spectacles has led to the fast and
furious franchise where each movie tries
to top the car stunts in the last
today's filmmakers build on all the
tools we've previously seen
but have to deal with a whole other set
of challenges
first cities have become more
restrictive about productions filming
risky chase sequences in their streets
so it's become commonplace to shoot
chases in an entirely different city
than they're sat in
fast and furious tokyo drift was despite
its title
mostly filmed in la the movie's vfx team
created an
entirely cg shibuya crossing the focal
point of a major chase in the movie and
used computer simulation to create fake
crowds and traffic
similarly the zombie chase and fate of
the furious was set in new york city
but filmed mostly in cleveland with
digital set extensions adding detailed
architecture to disguise the city
streets
the cars themselves are another common
hurdle chase cars aren't built the same
way today
since the decline of the muscle car
beginning in the late 70s
models have been getting safer and safer
today's cars have onboard computers that
make them shut down
if they start to drift or do a power
slide or j turn
basically all moves that would be
dangerous for your average driver
but make up the basic ingredients of a
hollywood chase scene
black panther's filmmakers ran into this
problem when filming the busan chase
scene
they had to have lexus send them a
computer programmer to tweak the car's
computer systems on set
overriding the many safety features this
happened on baby driver too
the team had to fly in a technician from
germany to make the mercedes-benz slide
around and crash through a fence without
shutting down
this customization goes beyond computer
programs
cars have always been reinforced and
modified for stunts but recent movies
take customization
much further for cars used in production
for the fast and furious movies the crew
removes the airbags from the cars and
disables features like traction control
and the anti-lock braking system
they also fortify the frames and bodies
of the vehicles so they can withstand
heavy duty stunt work this can also mean
building new cars from scratch
like the flip car that luke evans
character uses as a weapon
in the london chase from fast fix the
formula one style car has a special ramp
design
so that when it drives into other cars
it makes them go flying
they also designed the car with both
front and rear hydraulic steering which
made it possible for the car to change
direction at high speeds
and look like it's gliding over the road
but just as it took a hundred years to
get the tech to where we are now it can
still take
months to build up an epic car shot even
a short one
for the upcoming f9 movie director
justin lin said this
four second shot with a toyota 86 took
eight months of prep
four days of production and over a
hundred crew members
so even if these cars are going fast
it's the slow work of production that's
gotten chase scenes to where they are
[Music]
today